hi Tim how are you today oh you're
lead-in to getting much better you're
getting close to the truth with me
you're almost up there in the Woody
Paige stratosphere on around the horn
still got a ways to go but clearly
clearly number two I did pass Jay Mary
audience shows earlier this year so that
was there was something of a Toronto
could Woody Paige still take you in a
fight mmm
I think I can move a little quicker I
think I could stick and move okay I'd
like to see but really you couldn't
powerful man you couldn't take Tony
around you you had him in the studio
he's very very very fast twitch very
he's a little quick for me he's wispy
wispy and wired yes all right Tim that's
all I needed I appreciate you joining us
Amita caves next week how is this plan
locally in Dallas that Zeke gets to play
Sunday night but his status after that
is in limbo
I think it's confused I mean I think
people are obviously excited he's
playing against the Giants gives them a
much better chance against their top
division rival but the idea that he
might disappear after that and not be
seen until November is a little scary
for cowboy fans and you know the fact
that Henderson gave at the six games
fans feel like a rubber stamp
what Goodell did but that's kind of what
eventually the court is going to do the
same thing I think I think Zeke can win
in court for a short period of time and
maybe get the injunction and be able to
play but ultimately it's going to end up
the same way the brady case did I think
our Dallas fans more upset with the
Commissioner or ZQ Elliot the
Commissioner I should say there's some
aspect of fans that read this stuff that
came out over the weekend you know his
own testimony about what he did at Ohio
State and with the girl and all and
they're they're probably a little
shocked by it but by and large
fans are upset with the Commissioner
with myself with anybody else who isn't
just staunchly in the in the category of
you know Zico Zeta said he was set up by
this girl and if you if you see it any
other way your your your you're naive
wait
so they're they're angry at you with how
you see this well I mean I think Zeke
has brought a lot of these problems on
himself and even you know I can't I've
never I've never once written or said
that he is guilty I have no idea if he
is I just said there's enough there for
the league to determine he was now when
the league comes out over the weekend
and it you know the the woman who
investigated Kia Roberts who
investigated Tiffany Thompson apparently
is not allowed to be part of the
decision-making process yeah that is a
beyond a horrible look for the league
and that is the kind of thing that I
think you know should be able to get it
beat in court but everybody tells us
that it won't matter because the Brady
case ultimately came down to a judge
saying Goodell has the right to use
facts as he sees fit because this is
this all this power has been given him
and we're not going to fight that power
do you think that the well how's Jerry
Jones taken this you know he's been
unbelievably silent on the matter in the
wake of the six game suspension before
that he was saying there was going to be
death yeah and yeah recently said
there's going to be some good news but I
think you just had good news like I
think he thought he was gonna be able to
play in week one but I think he is I
mean this is this is not an easy match
for Jerry Jerry could overpower a lot of
people he cannot overpower the
commissioner in the league and I think
that's frustrating Ford is this his
Super Bowl team I mean Harold Henderson
was at his party at the Hall of Fame
that didn't go well
think about that he had the corndogs and
the donuts with everybody else and he
still gave him 60 games to answer your
question know it that's what's
interesting I think next year is a much
more likely if you think about this
they're much better getting this
over with now doc in his third year Zeke
in his third year all these young
defensive actually drafted to replace
their guys will be in their second year
right now they're all hurt
Jaylon Smith in his second year back to
this monster injury I would think 2018
is their year to really make a run you
know not saying they don't have a chance
this year but I think it's it'd be
easier to do it next year so I would if
I'm a cowboy fan I want to get this
suspension over with and get on with
Zeke's career and move forward because
it's a good young team he's Tim Callie
Shaw from around the horn joining us Dan
Patrick show yeah trying to understand
Ezekiel Elliott and what he'll mean on
Sunday night against the Giants and then
if it's Darren McFadden after that is it
going to be that much of a drop-off in
in the play calling and does this now
then rest with dak Prescott if Zeke is
down for six games I think like 15 to 20
percent I don't think there's that
there'll be a shift in the play calling
but not a lot they you know Zeke the way
they use eke last year was he frequently
would have six to eight carries in the
first half and then he'd have like 14
the 15 in the second half and they would
just you know open things up early but
then where people Dale with Zeke in the
second half and I don't know if they can
do that with Darren McFadden I don't
think they can use him to that extent so
it's gonna have to be a little more dak
but the feeling is you know he and he
and dad's are on the same page des is
healthier than he was a year ago so I
don't really think the offense I mean
it's stupid to say they won't miss and
they'll miss him a little yeah and it
might cost him one of the six games but
trying to figure out what they're gonna
do on defense is still a bigger puzzle
for this team would you voted for Jerry
Jones for the whole thing I would not
have I'm not the only one around here
who wrote okay baby that's why I wasn't
it's party wrote repeatedly I think you
should be in the Hall of Fame for
business or something else but they're
basically this is a bunch of people
saying he made the rich guys
filthy rich I mean that I mean the NFL
with the way TV has gone we've seen it
in every contract a smaller league these
contracts were going to be enormous now
he helped he helped push him toward Fox
25 years ago and he has a beautiful
Stadium are those reasons to be in the
Pro Football Hall of Fame when you're
the general manager of your team and you
haven't done anything in 20 years I
don't know to be it's not yeah I
wouldn't put it in the Hall of Fame
great businessman
you would not know no I wouldn't put him
in the Hall of Fame you know
contributions for the game yes
absolutely
okay yeah Robert Kraft has done more
than Jerry Jones has as far as
assembling a dynasty here Jerry hasn't
done I think Jerry has gotten in the way
of the Cowboys any attempts at success
the last 20 years so I can't give I
can't be stole him the best on or
greatest honor when I don't think you've
done a good job as an owner and a GM
most important thing an owner does is
what hire a GM I are the best GM you kid
yeah and that's where Jerry has failed
but I wouldn't have put a lot of these
guys and I said before I'd I wouldn't
have put Eddie DeBartolo in I mean he
hired a loss and he avoided prison time
in Louisiana those are two big cookies
way to go Eddie yeah but Robert Kraft
though Hall of Famer just for the shirts
just for bringing back the blue shirt
white collar
I mean French cause I was killing back
then are you one around the horn today I
am not I was I was a loser yesterday but
I will be back Friday hopefully to
preview Federer and Nadal because I'm
the only person on the show who cares
about or watches tennis so there I will
be there Friday to set the table for
that man all right well then I'm not
watching around the horn until Friday
you know what will edit that out I don't
want that to come back and haunt you
yeah
this is all yeah this is tape this is
tape yeah yeah don't worry about well
good yeah we're good all right Tim thank
you thank you for joining us that's Tim
Kalwa show the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience